- I grew up in the parallel universe
that used the E.
I remember it was the Berenstein Bears.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- So if there's really good memory
and there's really bad memory,
I would say I'm in the middle.
- Long term memory, great.
Short term memory, (murmuring).
- My memory's okay,
but like going downhill as I get older.
- So I feel like I have
a pretty good memory.
- Oh, is it Sex in the City
or Sex and the City?
That's the question.
- I have gone on Sex and
the City benders before.
- Sex and the City, baby.
(bell chiming)
- No, is it not?
Am I wrong?
- [Man] Incorrect.
- Incorrect?
- You have sex in a city.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- It's, "Mirror, mirror on the wall.
"Who's the fairest of them all?"
- Well, isn't it mirror, mirror?
(bell chiming)
- What?
- Magic mirror, no.
- No it's not.
You're lying.
♫ It's a beautiful day in the neighborhood
- The neighborhood?
This neighborhood?
Which neighborhood?
(bell chiming)
- A beautiful day in this,
he does not sing it like that.
- Dude, this is also bad
songwriting if it's this.
- Is it?
I don't know.
That doesn't sound right.
Someone should have given him a note.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Blank, "I am your father."
- Dad?
- Now I know it's not gonna
be whatever's obvious.
- Is it Luke?
- Guessing it's this.
(bell chiming)
- This is dumb.
That is so silly.
- I'm gonna go home and cry now.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Shazam?
Shablam?
- I don't know of any movie
featuring Sinbad as a genie.
- Shazam.
- There was no movie.
(bell chiming)
- What?
There's no movie called Shazam?
- Who am I?
- I'm just gonna look at that real quick.
That's not possible.
I've seen the movie Shazam.
He's a genie in it.
- The Berenstein Bears.
- Alright, well, now I'm upset.
(bell chiming)
- No it's not.
- Berenstain,
that says Berenstain.
- I don't know who's lobbying for big A,
but I'm just gonna say it's some nonsense,
and those bears deserve better.
- I hate life.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- (sighing) Everything has been a lie.
- I refuse to change my mind.
I think those signs are
from a alternate universe.
- I don't think it's implausible to assume
that there's billions
of alternate timelines
all occurring at once on
different planes of existence.
I mean, you know, there's no
movie called Shazam apparently,
so I guess anything's (beeping) possible.
- I'd like to think that I'm
from the parallel universe
with a lot of dogs,
lots of color blue, weird people.
I'd be fine with that.
- Shazam is real.
Shazam is real.